ya hablamos de la idea o tesis de que si
el rendimiento del capital es mayor que
el rendimiento de la economía nos podría
llevar a la desigualdad aunque mostramos
un ejemplo en el que dependiendo de las
circunstancias esto no necesariamente
tiene que pasar pero lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es analizar de manera
crítica ciertos datos del libro
nuevamente mi objetivo no es apoyar o
criticar lo que plantea el libro sino
darles herramientas para poder pensar de
manera crítica sobre todas estas ideas
del libro algo muy bueno y que ya he
mencionado en vídeos anteriores es que
el autor ha publicado en su sitio web
todas las gráficas del libro esta es su
dirección electrónica esta gráfica en
particular es muy interesante es la tasa
de rendimiento versus tasa de
crecimiento a nivel mundial desde la
antigüedad hasta el 2100 y no vender
muchas gráficas que comiencen en el año
cero y consideren un periodo de 2000
años así que pueden imaginar que los
números de aquí
son estimaciones pero supongamos que son
acertados para simplificar nuestro
análisis esto muestra el rendimiento
puro de capital después de impuestos y
pérdidas de capital y esto de aquí es la
tasa de crecimiento de salida mundial y
vemos que durante la mayor parte de los
últimos miles de años de la historia
mundial aunque este eje horizontal no se
encuentra exactamente a escala de aquí
acá tenemos 1500 años mientras que de
aquí aquí tenemos 50 años pero podemos
ver que durante la mayor parte de la
historia de la humanidad la tasa de
crecimiento anual de la economía ha sido
mucho menor que la tasa de rendimiento
del capital nuevamente estas son
estimaciones especialmente aquí basados
en épocas feudales y otras cosas aunque
son creíbles ya que en tiempos feudales
cuando había reyes y cosas por el estilo
había mucha coerción por parte de los
reyes y señores feudales los cuales
forzaban a las personas a trabajar en
sus campos
hicieron pero si tomamos estos números
vemos que sucede algo interesante
conforme llegamos a inicios del siglo 20
el rendimiento del capital después de
impuestos cae por debajo del crecimiento
económico aunque esto se da en grandes
períodos de tiempo por ejemplo este
punto de aquí representa 37 años y aquí
tenemos otro punto de datos que
representa los 62 años siguientes y
representa el mundo que la mayoría de
nosotros conocemos esta es la época
moderna en donde la tasa de crecimiento
de salida mundial ha sido más grande que
la tasa del rendimiento de capital
después de impuestos cuando vemos esta
gráfica por primera vez vemos que uno
las líneas se van a cruzar otra vez y
quizás esto signifique que vamos a
regresar a la edad de oro o edad dorada
pero aquí hay que tener mucho cuidado
todo lo que se encuentre después de este
punto son conjeturas solamente es un
modelo y podría o no suceder podríamos
ver algo muy diferente
esto que estoy resaltando son sólo
conjeturas podría ocurrir lo contrario
es posible que tengamos una realidad en
donde la tendencia sea así vaya el
crecimiento de aquí acá o haga algo así
lo importante es notar que este punto de
acá esta intersección es una proyección
estas son sólo suposiciones y ustedes
deben decidir por ustedes mismos si
consideran que esta proyección tiene
sentido porque esto es lo que dice que
esta delta o diferencia de aquí / rc en
la que se es más grande que r se termina
pero quizá no se termina quizá si
promediamos los siguientes 38 años
tengamos algo así y este es el mero
inicio de este intervalo también se
supone que aunque esto ocurriera se
supone que va a tenerse esta relación
ere mayor que se que implica desigualdad
la cual en formas extremas eventualmente
llevaría a otra edad de oro oa riquezas
dignas de una dinastía los cuales
podrían afectar la innovación riquezas
riquezas dinásticas
y esto afecta la meritocracia
o potencialmente la innovación
innovación
a la economía en su totalidad ya que
tendríamos menos personas de clase media
o personas con poder adquisitivo aquí
hay muchas flechas y ustedes necesitan
decidir por su cuenta que partes de esta
conexión están ustedes de acuerdo o en
desacuerdo dependiendo de las
circunstancias o de las evidencias